let's talk about the rights
sick depraved obsession with a guy named
Hunter Biden now I know many of you are
evaluating and thinking about
how has the presidency of Joe Biden gone
has he done good things has he done bad
things has he not done enough things or
is he doing too much is his perspective
on uh gun safety the right perspective
we're talking about the president
there is a large swath of people and
many of them are in positions of power
many of them are people who have large
microphones some literally large and
some proverbial metaphorically large
microphones who are obsessed not with
Joe Biden they're not alone with Joe
Biden but with a guy named Hunter bite
now Hunter Biden has no role whatsoever
in his father's Administration
simply none it's not like Jared Kushner
or Ivanka who were involved in their
fathers and father-in-law's
Administration Hunter is not trying nor
does he have any role in Joe Biden's
Administration and yet there are many on
the right who are obsessed with him
there's a really good article which we
will link to in the description to the
YouTube video call up by Michael tomasky
uh for New Republic it was published
yesterday called there's nothing
Stranger Than the rights fixation with
Hunter Biden now the article is
excellent it depends how you want to
interpret this but on the one hand it is
a bizarre hyper fixation on Hunter Biden
from the right on the other hand it's
also kind of not and we're going to talk
about that the sort of catalyst for this
article which uh I encourage you to read
was the Twitter files bombshell that
flopped over the weekend a Twitter
thread published by journalist Matt
taibi
um and a couple important things to
highlight here the article reads what
exactly is at the root of the rights
Hunter Biden obsession
at its simplest level the hunter Saga is
just a potential Achilles heel for a
president they want to defeat in 2024
assuming Joe Biden runs I think that
that's right I think that they don't
really care about Hunter Biden
in and of itself but they care about
Hunter Biden as a possible way to hurt
Joe Biden in 2024. but that has never
quite explained the article goes on the
manic quality of the drive to turn
Hunter into the symbol and standard
bearer of the democratic party and of
liberalism generally it had to have
something to do I always thought with
the notion that Hunter represents the
licentiousness with which conservatives
associate liberals his drug use his
sketchy affair with his dead brother's
wife and now his entry into the effect
and vaguely Un-American Manhattan art
world but this weekend things got even
weirder
and in ways that were so sorted it took
me a while to even understand what was
going on
if you had the good fortune or sense not
to crawl down this particular Rabbit
Hole over the weekend fear not I won't
drag you into the depths that I
descended the briefest recap is this on
Friday Elon Musk tweeted he would reveal
how Twitter supposedly covered up the
hunter Biden scandal in October 2020
Matt taibi posted some of the emails
found on Hunter's hard drive some showed
the Biden campaign asking Twitter to
refrain from posting certain material
that's basically it
in some quarters of the right this is
the biggest scandal in the history of
the Republic because it allegedly proves
that Biden used his governmental power
he by the way didn't control any of the
government at the time to set fire to
the Constitution musk tweet it if this
isn't a violation of the Constitution's
First Amendment what is there are a
couple different things that I believe
are important to mention here first of
all
if we want to go back to the source of
all of this the hunter Biden laptop
itself
what's in a sense ironic is that
everything there that definitively
touches Joe Biden makes Joe Biden look
really good what I mean by that is that
there are lots of allegations the right
makes about the Joe Biden connection
they say Well when the messages refer to
the big guy getting a cut
it's about Joe Biden there's no evidence
of that at this point in time could it
be true sure there is no evidence of
that at this point in time the things we
know relate to Joe Biden that we have
uncovered based on these emails are that
Joe Biden really loves Hunter
that Joe Biden really
expressed empathy for Hunter's drug use
and and drug problems Etc
um the voice message where he says it's
Dad I called to tell you I love you the
right tried to make this
a frame Biden as being weak
the truth is Don Jr probably wishes his
dad talked to him that way and told him
he loved him uh that relationship
doesn't really seem quite so good but
the truth is that everything we
definitively have linked
to Joe Biden from the laptop makes him
look pretty good and the reality is that
conservatives don't really have
the indictment of Joe Biden anywhere
that exists of trump and that's why they
are making it all about Hunter Biden and
in his article Michael tomasky
eventually gets to this exact conclusion
the hunter Crusade he writes is thus
driven not only by pursuit of Scandal to
hang around his father's neck it is
rooted in the rights antique and cruel
value system which most Americans no
longer share should Republicans catch
hunter in some genuinely corrupt or
illegal Arrangement so be it let him pay
his debt to society if they don't they
will be left wondering why America
doesn't share their seething hatred of a
man whom the Jesus they claim to worship
would have counseled us to regard with
compassion this is fundamentally what
this is all about and there's two sides
to this now to get back to the bizarre
nature of the obsession on the one hand
it is bizarre they're obsessed with
someone so meaningless not as a person
every person has value meaningless in
the context of figuring out is the
country going in the right or wrong
direction
What policies of Joe bidens have been
helpful versus damaging to the economy
or to foreign policy or whatever it's
meaningless in that sense and that is
bizarre but at the same time
hyper focus on irrelevant issues has
been the name of the game for this
Republican party for four six probably
more like eight or even closer to ten
years at this point in time and that
really shouldn't surprise us at all
one of our sponsors is Helix sleep I
have been sleeping on a helix mattress
for years and I always recommend it to
friends you'd simply take this Helix
sleep quiz it asks you about your body
type your sleep position whether you
have back pain and then Helix will match
you up with the mattress that is
personalized to your needs and they ship
it to you for free another reason I went
with Helix is that unlike a lot of
mattress companies out there every
single Helix mattress is made in the USA
by a skilled production team which means
when you buy a helix mattress you're
supporting great jobs I'm not the only
one who loves Helix Helix was recently
awarded number one mattress by both GQ
and Wired Magazine every Helix mattress
comes with a 10 or 15 year warranty you
can try it a hundred nights and send it
back for a full refund if you need to
support the David Pacman show by getting
your next mattress from Helix sleep and
and you'll get up to 350 off any
mattress plus two free pillows when you
go to Helix sleep.com slash Pacman the
link is down below